the TD Jakes group and Wells Fargo are
announcing a 10-year partnership to
build communities for all income levels
now this partnership includes a
commitment of one up to one billion
dollars with a B from Wells Fargo to
help pay for various projects their
first project is a mixed income housing
and Retail development outside Atlanta
the nearly 95-acre property is a former
Army base Fort McPherson which is right
next to Tyler Perry Studios the TD Jakes
group is a conglomerate of four business
units TD Jakes Ministries and TD Jakes
Foundation those are non-profits while
TD Jake's Enterprises and TD Jakes real
estate Ventures are for profit entities
TD Jakes himself also presides Over The
Potter's House Church but the church is
not affiliated with this Wells Fargo
partnership we welcome you Bishop it's
so good to have you at this oh thank you
it's good to be in here you have a lot
going on in your life but explain
exactly how this is going to work and
why you wanted to do it now I think it's
imperative the fierce urgency of now
indicates to us the fact that the future
looks very Bleak particularly for
minorities black people brown people and
also poor white people who are finding
it difficult Workforce people to find a
job to find Opportunities to get housing
to get upward Mobility to have
communities that are built in uh
repressed neighborhoods and Revitalize
the community giving the homeowners who
live there are people who lived in the
community
a chance to stay there for affordable
rates so this is an exciting moment for
us we're really really thrilled to be
able to do it so Wells Fargo is
committing to up to a billion dollars to
fund these projects pay for is the way
we put it that's not a donation right
that's an investment they want to make
money off well no no it's not I don't
know what they want to do but it's not a
donation it's a commitment to supporting
initiative to raise up communities that
have been repressed was was Wells Fargo
your only option on this or or what made
you comfortable with Wells Fargo and the
reason I ask that is you know they have
a recent history uh in fact just in
December they uh paid a 3.7 billion
dollar uh fine to settle accusations of
illegal overdraft fees illegal fees tied
to car loans illegal fees time to
mortgages this is money they were taking
out of the pockets of low-income people
that you're trying to help now right and
and that's exactly the reservations that
I had with them as well initially
several years ago when they talked to me
I would not do business with them for
those very reasons uh that settlement
that came out came from the previous
administration they have a new leader
now they have a new Administration and
they're beginning to write some of the
wrongs this it's not going to write at
all at once but it is a start toward uh
justifying and rectifying some of the
mistakes that have been made previously
the other reason is when other Banks
stood back and looked Wells Fargo stood
up and said you know I'm willing to make
this unlikely Alliance it's very uh
unique Alliance I've written a book
called disruptive thinking and this
disruptive alliance between us is
designed to lift up underserved
underrepresented Community what do you
get out of this bishop being involved in
this part first and primary thing for me
is Legacy you know it's it's a legacy
piece for me I want to give back I want
to do something for uh people who have
been loyal and faithful to me and people
that I know and love the second thing
that I get out of it is knowing that we
have headed off a collision that the
stats say that by 20 50 the average
median income for black people is going
to be zero and so we have got to get in
front of this with steam with technology
with job creation with entrepreneurship
with mixed income housing and schools
closing food deserts doing things like
that I think are vitally important for
the future and you want to make sure
that people understand this is not
low-income housing this is mixed income
housing you might want to make that note
well we probably use that mean exactly
yeah
mixed income housing means that you your
neighbor across the street might be a
doctor somebody else might be working
for FedEx and somebody else might be
underemployed in a janitor the reason
mixed income housing is vitally
important is because we've tried
low-income communities before and they
fall into the abyss and become ghettos
mixed income have a much better result
safer better schools better
opportunities up with Mobility finally
when children are raised in homes
without fathers the stats say if they
live near somebody who has a father they
have better outcomes in seeing not
seeing that at all right so for all of
those reasons including Health maladies
and so food deserts just so many things
that we're doing in our communities
that are in alignment with some of the
objectives that Wells Fargo has and I'm
excited to be the point about fatherhood
is so interesting yeah just having more
fathers in the neighborhood right is
important and is correlated with better
outcomes particularly for Sons
absolutely absolutely you said this time
sometimes we have to be disruptive in
less than 30 seconds that's what strikes
me about this deal well well look we are
the people we've been waiting on we
cannot sit back any longer and wait on
everybody to come rescue us we've got to
come up with these innovative ideas and
people with influence and opportunities
like mine want to lead the way because I
feel like it's my destiny to help the
Next Generation reach theirs yeah I have
to challenge old tradition to create new
ones I'm glad your destiny got you here
because I know you were the weather in
Texas is so bad I'm glad you're here so
bad I'm great to be here thanks for
having me it's been wonderful